believe it or not the media they did
want war with Syria and pretty pretty
intensely and over-the-top Lee a new Pew
study found that all cable news channels
were more in favor of war with Syria
than not going to war and that includes
the newest cable channel the cable news
channel al-jazeera which had promised a
different take and that they were going
to give us you know because we're so
controlled here by the media they were
going to give us something else turns
out not exactly let's look at some of
the numbers on this okay so this is
really kind of incredible and it shows
you how partisan everything has become
MSNBC sixty-four percent of their
messages about the war were pro war now
at the same point they also had the
highest number of mentions that were
anti-war so they tried to balance
themselves out a bit but as you can see
Fox was at 45 and then 20 against we got
a lot of there's a lot of numbers there
the base point is as you can see
everything on the blue on the left is
higher all the pro-war messages were
higher than the red ones so that just
gives you a few go if you don't want to
break down the numbers with us there you
get the sense with colors pretty good
should this not surprise us because the
media always wants to go to war cuz
that's when people watch the news I
guess it says in the article that all
the polls say that we don't want to but
we just came from more like can we get a
second take a breather like holy crap
you know um I think that I think they
all I mean this maybe is a conspiracy
theory but I feel like we all have a
combined interest whether they're
liberal or conservative or whatever box
you want to put al Jazeera in um I think
they're all after money and I think war
creates revenue for people and I think
that that's ultimately like it's in
there it's in certain people's best
interest to go to war even though it's
not good for the country i think other
people have their right so it's an MSNBC
example perfect example of if this was
bush wanting to go to war obviously
MSNBC wouldn't have been a war so it
just shows you they're all picking aside
with their guys so Fox was against this
war because they don't like Obama I mean
this is this is psych 101 right it's
definitely not shocked though I mean
people tune in when there's a disaster
when there's war
were like that's when they're glued to
the TV's I mean think about when the
trades owners went done anything like
that I mean you become immersed in these
stories you know and so they want to
push for it and I think with MSNBC I
think what's happening there is that you
know that is their kind of targeting
their demographic that's watching it in
terms of like that's their main story I
think Fox has like other stories they
tackle on them because their demographic
might also be more simpler than other
sects of things you know and yeah that
was my pc way of putting things you know
and i think that's why they talk about
it more because even i mean democrats
want to hear about it because they want
to be like you know kind of stand behind
we're not going or about you know this
and that but um now i think it's
absolutely no shocker i mean people if
you look at local news they talk about
car crashes murders and you rarely hear
about something that's positive
happening in the world is a shocker and
it's about five seconds Long's yeah so
is the fascinating part of this that
al-jazeera did the same basically the
same sort of pro-war messaging that the
other three did because people thought
they were going to come in and give us
somehow more of a balanced approach or
something more pro arabs so to speak but
you know they're based in qatar which
has obviously ties to saudi arabia saudi
arabia was offering for us to pay for us
to go to war so is it sort of just this
big it's just this big mess of but
there's money and like keeping up with
the Joneses I mean really is it like
news channels have to keep up with what
other news channels are doing because
there's obviously some type of you know
recipe for success people are tuning in
so if one station doesn't do it to a
certain level are people going to just
go to the next one yeah I guess it's a
little bit of just sort of like a
rallying cry like if everyone's like
let's go to war let's go to war there's
not that much excitement and let's not
go to war like how much programming yeah
like these are a target yeah looks like
reality television you don't tune in to
see the girls like all get along with
you look amazing
you tune in for the former like you look
amazing you look at me an interview like
that [ __ ] so I can't believe this [ __ ]
you know so like obviously there you
know the ratings are more for for the
tension and and all of that and we like
to do it in to see things like that
versus like nice good stories
unfortunately yeah